i don't know where ufc goes from here
because i would i would
i would call myself a casual fan meaning
i don't know much about ufc
but if conor mcgregor's fighting i'm
gonna watch it
now without conor i don't know who i
would give two shits about i don't think
about that i get that i'm just saying me
i wouldn't go watch it but let me just
important
not that billy mcgillicuddy but you're
gonna watch let me explain no i'm not i
promise you guys what happened
let me tell you why you're gonna watch
here's why you're gonna watch okay
never underestimate the power of a dana
white what are we talking about here
like
when when dana had a couple guys step
away you forget who stepped away like
you want to go back and look at the list
of play
put down the greatest ufc fighters of
all time can you put them up just put
the greatest ufc fighters of all time
randy i don't know where you're going
with this let me nobody's even close to
drawing what connor does
listen but i'm i'm i'm sweating stop
stop go
greatest ufc fighters all the time when
khabib stepped away they said it's over
who's gonna watch it okay keep going up
keep going up i never even heard of
khabib bj pemberton
that's the point royce gracie keep going
these are these are all killers
keep going keep going up keep going up
with these names keep going up with
these names keep going
keep going up keep regular even heard of
these things top five silva
go to top five usman is still in the
game you got uh
liddell that would have been relevant
ten years i know when they
stepped away they said the league is
that the
ufc is going to be boring keep going
keep going keep going keep going 7-6
khabib is gone cormier cormier's gone a
lot of these guys
george saint pierre was like gone years
ago but what i'm trying to tell you is
the franchise keeps getting bigger and
bigger
anderson silva was a god jon jones god
this guy's had gods jon jones would come
in
in the press conference would knock the
other guy out in press conference
i mean you're talking about guys that
sold out arenas where people would come
from around
you got to bank on dana but this is
about counterwriting it's not about
being listen i'm a buy and hold guy with
conor i bought his best card this is his
rookie 2013 tops
ufc bloodlines psa 10 gemint and auto
10. this is connor
i'm a buy and hold guy the only thing
that concerns me about connor is when he
plays
the spouse and the religion game you
cannot do that you become a target
you cannot play that game i understand
like ronda rousey sent a message right
afterwards i don't know if you guys saw
what rhonda said about him right
afterwards can you pull up ronda's
tweet right afterwards towards conor did
you guys read that i didn't see it so
ronda said this about conor the next uh
uh just pull it up let's see uh yeah
pull up um
uh is it this one okay uh uh so i'm
amazed that as soon as you hit the
ground you were already promoting the
next fight
i definitely wouldn't have had that in
mind to do that the other fighters ufc
and the media are lucky to have you i
disagree
everybody in the world is lucky to have
conor mcgregor
everybody is lucky to have conor
mcgregor but to have that mindset will
you drop
first thing you're thinking about is the
next fight are you a promoter or a
fighter i don't know are you still
promoting to make money or are you
so my mind goes to a couple different
places here's a couple different places
it goes to a counter
some guy right now commented and says
he's not gone somebody said let me read
who it was
it says scott smith gave 10 bucks and so
i'll make the argument conor was
dominating their second bout
uh connor looked amazing in the third
bout i don't know about that maybe in
the first 90 seconds but the moment he
was down he was gone connor ain't done
he was gearing up to take pacquiao okay
i agree here's a problem scott and it's
my opinion
amateur opinion somebody can destroy my
argument but this is my argument
when i was talking to tim grover here's
what tim grover said
tim has meant tim is uh training uh
jordan
and when he's training jordan jordan
decides to go out there and uh play
baseball he says i want to go play
baseball
tim says the entire conditioning has
officially changed
this is what do you mean he says to
prepare your body for baseball
it's very different than preparing your
body for basketball
it's a very different conditioning and
it's going to take a while to do that
what's the point to prepare a
conditioning for boxing
pacquiao is very different than to
prepare
a fight in ufc boxing you ain't going to
the ground everybody knows conor is a
great boxer
but his ground game is not the best
you're going against guys where you have
to spend
majority of your time working in areas
where you don't do well with
let's set up let's say tell what
happened with this guy he's been choked
out he's been
khabib got him on the ground he doesn't
do well on the ground once he he didn't
want to go down
when he bit diaz how did he beat diaz
first fight he lost he went to the
ground
second fight if you see that one scene i
don't know if you guys remember this
with diaz
they're going at it he's punching diaz
he falls down he punches him said can i
be full remember that he punches him he
falls down
and diaz is like come on come on come
get me connor's standing up he's not
going
that message tells you you come to the
ground i'm going to destroy you and
connor says i know i'm not good there
but i'm good at stand up so stand in a
stand up game he's got but if you're
going against some of these other guys
make a point i'm gonna ask you a
question one through ten
ten being the most one being i don't
give a [ __ ] here we go
where are you on a being a fan of ufc
i'm i'm a fan what number eight and a
half you're an eight and a half yeah
i'm a six point five i'm a five and i go
for the stars
okay meaning a guy like you who's at
eight and a half a nine and ten
they're gonna watch ufc regardless six
and a half
maybe you're gonna watch maybe not a
five i'm only watching if a guy like
conor mcgregor is fighting
if pick a name is is fighting pick a
name
dude i never even heard of khabib until
like a year ago dana white doesn't give
a [ __ ] to have a fan like you what are
you talking about
he does the conversation are you talking
are you
out of your mind dude let me ask you a
question let me ask you a question
let me ask you a question you want a
simple question how much money have you
ever made for ufc
you like 50 bucks when was it i bought
one fight with connor
okay there you have it made him [ __ ] so
who cares if he loses you
got i bought no you don't mean anything
today no wrong approach you're not a
spender
that's the wrong approach it's not the
wrong approach you're not a spender
you're not a guy that's bringing
revenues to the brand that's like david
stern when he was promoting the nba
being like
we don't need to expand we have our base
they love the nba they're buying seasons
but then he invested in jordan he
invested in hours
you're making a mistake and comparing
dana to freaking
david stone what are you talking about
saying dude
do you know what part of the world ufc
is fighting can you pull up
different countries ufc has had a fight
in give me a free what you just said
right there was ludicrous
says you know nothing about what's going
on with you he's saying are you casual
what are you talking about you're not a
spender though you're irrelevant to ufc
you're only thinking in terms of
monetization talking about you you are
irrelevant to ufc
that's it dana white me and you are done
you are irrelevant to ufc here we go you
ready
okay u.s brazil canada uk australia
japan
china germany sweden mexico ireland
singapore dubai united
arab emirates netherlands new zealand
poland russia argentina chile croatia
do you want me to keep going this guy's
a global brag
i woke up saying i better get adam
saunders
you know what this was good they should
say i could i'd watch two rounds of this
i pay 50 bucks for you
to continue the question isn't about
dana white
he's the best commissioner in sports as
a matter of fact i'd make the argument
that
he should be i agree with you he should
do a two-year term in every sport and
fix every sport while he's at it by the
way i spent a couple hours with
uh dana white one time flew up hung out
with him in his office did this long
interview
with him his office i may have mentioned
this before it is the
you can tell there's no hr department at
ufc when you walk into dana white's
office it is flat out unbelievable what
you see in there
but let me bring this back to the topic
and you two are both delusional and so
is everybody else that said
conor mcgregor is relevant as a ufc
fighter a
number one there's no sport where hunger
controls
everything if you're not hungry you are
dead
or seriously injured in ufc you are
completely irrelevant and you have no
chance
to fight at the highest level what does
he give you
in his mind part of it's going i hope
this ends soon i hope i don't get hurt
he's not this he's not the same guy
he is not the same guy as a fighter that
doesn't mean he isn't one of the top
global stars in the country and he's not
going to be relevant forever
he's elvis jumpsuit as a fighter i want
to know why i'm right on this one
because if we were talking about any
other fighter other than conor
this story would have been done you guys
have lost your mind other than conor
mcgregor
no one knows your mind you've lost your
mind no i'm out of control let me let me
ask you a question i'll watch if the
the dustin the diamond poirier actually
fights dustin diamond from saved by the
belt let me let me rest in peace let me
let me watch that fight let me shout out
the screech i miss you buddy let me put
it to you this way let me put it to you
this way
any game that is very good with their
number ones
is gonna have people that are gonna work
like dogs they're gonna work like
like military work like i'm talking work
work to go be number ones because they
take it our number ones
ufc may not be an organization that's
known for taking care of their number 80
or their number 40. we know the
criticism jake paul goes after him a lot
of people have been saying what they've
been saying about the fact that
a lot of the athletes are not making
money but if there's one thing ufc is
known for is what
they take care of their number one their
number ones are gonna make a lot of
money right
you know how many people right now are
sitting there this is what they're
thinking
how many people right now are saying
that position for number one is wide
open
i'm going to go get it same thing
happens to great sports when the
jordan left who's going to replace
jordan kobe kim kobe live who's going to
approach
lebron lebron look what's going on right
now with giannis giannis
2-1 they're down but he's got 40 points
back to back the last time in 1971.
oh by the way i just thought of
something what's that the the the guy i
couldn't even tell you his name
to uh he knocked the [ __ ] out of the uh
of uh greg hardy and he drank a beer out
of his shoe
i'm in on that guy okay all right you
who's that guy will you spend 20 bucks
on that guy
no save that money however what's that
guy's name not the customer i know he
knows what's up
matter what's his name what's his name
pvd what's his name nobody knows his
name
exactly nobody knows are you out of your
mind are you
insinuating that there is me and you we
each take a tennis shoe and we chug a
beer
for we'll donate the money to charity
first of all if you're watching this if
you're watching this if you're watching
this i'm actually curious let's see what
the audience
let me actually look at the ratio let me
actually look at the ratio so right now
we got 390 thumbs up to seven thumbs
down
okay how many of you think that connor
is not done
put thumbs up connor's not good as an
elite fighter
listen as an elite fighter he's gonna
come back and he's gonna put on a fight
and he's gonna win
again and maybe even have a shot at a
title fight
he's 32 years old today how many guys
think he's gonna make a comeback put
thumbs up if you think he's gonna make a
comeback
and redeem himself thumbs up if you say
the guy is done it's retirement time
put thumbs down what do you think on
which one it is
me last week when the fight took place i
commented i said the
the fan base is lucky to have a guy like
this to see him fight at his peak
and we've been talking about conor the
moment he got that 200 million dollar
payday from
proper 12 it's a different counter if
he's not willing to listen to a guy like
tim what he just said and going to that
place to want to fight again
we ain't going to see the best the best
days of connor are behind him if he does
go to that dark place and really want to
come back and make a come back and
redeem himself
we may see i don't know how you see it
right now let's see what the ratios are
couple quick comments when you're ready
uh number one the guy's name that i
didn't know was
uh tai tiavasa
okay that's number one number two um
in case we want to write this down where
did that go where did that go where did
that go
um the guy who said he's 41 years old
and he moved from cuba when he was seven
years old i'm looking for your comment
uh what number should he call if that's
the guy you want to talk to
you have it okay oh you have that hey by
the way how old was he when he moved
seven years ago okay good and shout out
to tom zenner they said
these are my three favorite combo pat
adam and tom thanks crypto mike
shout out to tom zenner right there okay
thank you hey by the way the guy had
some great comments is khabib
after this fight and he broke it down
and said hey this is who conor is
when you know when he was on the ground
now there tmz had a story where there
was a side angle of a camera where he
was actually threatening to kill
uh portier's wife and and and him he's
going to shoot him in the head in the
middle of this
club he can't do that so khabib's point
is this guy is nothing but a low-rank
punk
you know his true colors dustin called
these guys have legitimate hate for him
and the last thing that um
conor mcgregor wants to do is step in a
ring with khabib when he threw that
stanchion at the bus in brooklyn or in
new york city at madison square
but you know what in conor's mind it's
all promotion
and i think everything is on the table
when it comes to him
everything and that's why the next step
for him has to be an event that he can
actually win
he has no chance of winning a ufc fight
unless he's fighting a guy like cyrone
or cowboy the guy the last guy he beats
but that's not but that's who he can be
he's not real he'd be that guy like
three seconds
believe it or not the ratio is is 53
think his best
he can come back and have a title fight
35 think he's done which means
a lot of people are saying the best days
of conor are behind them and we may
never see by the way i don't know if
this is something we can pull up i'd
like to see
the numbers pay-per-view revenue with
connor without connor
i bet you it's a complete difference
sure it is okay sure my point but there
is a guy
yeah that you keep forgetting about you
keep forgetting about the guy you know
what cop
who is forgetting about it he's one of
the greatest promoters
instigators of all time the guy's going
to figure out a way to do it fyi i think
there's only one connor though bro
oh my gosh stop i don't he's that
brilliant of a marker you know what let
me tell you something man
one of the things that you [ __ ] right
here one of the things i respect about
what michael said well michael was
coming up and he was retiring and he was
done
and now lebron comes into the league and
they ask him about jersey why you were
number six why don't you wear number 23
and all this stuff and lebron said
i think we should retire to number 23
nobody should ever wear it again
remember what michael said
michael said the nba is bigger than one
player
he says i appreciate the compliment but
the nba is bigger than me it's a bigger
franchise than i am
it's going to continue what does lebron
do he goes and wears number 23.
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye